your journey to self-realization will be
unique to you and you alone this is very
hard for Humanity at large to grasp
because the mind is always looking for a
consensus it wants to know the answer it
wants to know what's the best diet
what's going to happen what's the best
technology what's the best training
practice it wants to create these boxes
of some truth because it makes the ego
or the personality feel more comfortable
more safe but the truth of the matter is
we are billions of unique life forms
living in this realm and the experience
of life is unique for each of us and so
we have this wonderful blessing of life
and that is to discover who we are to
express ourselves and for me those
Treasures have been and will always be
residing in the heart